there is an effort being made by the
current administration and by the people
surrounding it to redefine what treason
is and it's genuinely menacing when we
see these authoritarian slides we have
to understand that they're often slow
slides it's the slow erosion of what it
means to have a truly free and
independent press for example and it
gets chipped away at a little bit at a
time by the idea of suing media outlets
journalism licenses stricter White House
press past policies the smears about
fake news it's a long list but they're
really slow attempt less and less
frequent press briefings by the White
House press secretary it's a slow
process that you have to observe from
afar rather than day to day another
example the slow erosion of the
independence of our branches of
government and the systems of checks and
balances including the investigative
power of the House and Senate ignoring
subpoenas getting your own attorney
general in there to manage the results
of an investigation into you etc etc etc
so it's important to realize that these
things happen slowly and it can be I
don't even know if this is an actual
thing but you often hear about the frog
that goes into a cold pan you start
heating up the pan heats up slowly the
Frog doesn't realize it's being burned
that may not even work maybe the Frog
just jumps out when it gets hot but
that's the metaphor that I think many of
us are familiar with and there is now a
slow but very sure and creeping slide to
redefine treason by the administration
yesterday Donald Trump published or
retweeted an article that quotes Liz
Cheney the daughter of former Vice
President Dick Cheney as saying that
statements made by agents investigating
Donald Trump could be treason and in the
length interview Liz Cheney even says
that FBI agents who investigated Trump
could have been attempting a coup these
are attempts at redefinition if you
control the language you control
everything I forget who where that quote
is from they are trying to control the
language treason treason is the crime of
betraying one's country especially by
attempting to kill the sovereign or
overthrow the government
that is not what the investigations into
Donald Trump sought to do they certainly
weren't attempting to kill the sovereign
and they were not attempting to
overthrow the government they were
investigating whether Donald Trump
specifically committed crimes a coup is
a sudden violent and illegal seizure of
power from a government of course those
investigating Donald Trump didn't
attempt to do that and if Donald Trump
were to leave there would be no seizure
of power from a government it would
likely be Mike Pence takes over although
there are other scenarios as well so
what you have to understand is that they
are systematically trying to change the
meaning of these things in order to
favor their position on whatever in this
case these investigations and in fact
Donald Trump was asked about his treason
claim recently a few days ago and look
at what happened and in further fact I
should mention as far as Liz Cheney is
concerned Liz Cheney if she wants to
talk about treason the closest thing to
treason she might be well-positioned to
comment on would be the war crimes that
her dad Dick Cheney participated in
within the Bush administration and even
then it is dubious whether you could
actually make a treason case there as
many legal experts have said so here's
Donald Trump asked about treason is
punishable by death who exactly are you
talking about - she says treason is
punishable by death you've accused your
adversaries of treason who specifically
are you accusing of treason well I think
a number of people and I think what you
look is that they have unsuccessfully
tried to take down the wrong person if
you look at Comey if you look at McCabe
if you look at probably people hot
people higher than that if you look at
struck if you look at his lover lisa
page his wonderful lover the two lovers
they talked openly you know they didn't
use their private server because they
didn't want to get caught so they used
the government server that was not a
good move he talked about the insurance
policy just in case crooked Hillary
losses and that didn't work out too well
for them so you look at them they want
an insurance policy so that should she
for any reason
remember 100 million to one maybe he
said 100 million to nothing but should
she lose we'll have an insurance policy
and we'll get this guy out of office and
that's what they said and that's what
they meant that's treason that's treason
they couldn't win the election and
that's what happened and that's what's
happening right now because without the
treason word I guess but that's what's
happening now James Comey John McCain
Peter struck who was working for Muller
and was dismissed when politically
biased private text messages went public
as far as Democrats not thinking they
can win without trying to remove from
forcibly or whatever it's the opposite
it's been Trump who has been saying
Democrats can't win fair and square in
2020 which is how Trump has been hinting
at the possibility of not accepting the
results of the election if he loses this
is complete and total projection and
there's a real question here I don't
know the answer to this if a president
publicly accused you of treason by name
is there any recourse is that defamation
the act of damaging the good reputation
of someone slander or libel when the
president says that specific individuals
have committed a crime but not just any
crime the crime of treason is there any
recourse that those individuals have and
is that really where we are right now
we've got to take control back there's
no other way around it this is becoming
extremely dangerous and these
redefinitions should be concerning to
everybody who's been paying attention to
what's going on and this is not
happening by accident this is a
concerted effort to start throwing
around the word treason particularly at
a time when what we are learning is that
there was wrongdoing by Trump remember
and everybody around him it's an attempt
to distract from that and instead say
the investigators are the individuals
who were treasonous we can't fall for it
and we've got to act sooner than later
November of 2020 in order to stop this
insanity